we've been called crazy a lot of times
by a lot of different people we were
coming with something that nobody had
ever put on the table before so people
didn't know how to react
my name is Camilla Sadler
we're in Bolivia in La Paz in restaurant
gusto where I'm the executive head chef
the SU is crazy restaurant on a mountain
it started out as a small culinary
school projects and then we decided to
go big
founded by globally celebrated chef
Klaus mile gusto is a unique culinary
experiment in social outreach the goal
proving that food can do more than just
feed people it can educate and inspire
one of the poorest countries in Latin
America but with an abundance of diverse
and obscure ingredients Bolivia seemed
to be the perfect spot to set up shop
the idea of giving something back in a
development country is where gusto comes
into the picture
goo stirs goal is to train a new
generation of the Libyans to cook
prepare and serve high-end cuisine using
only Bolivian ingredients goose is not
meant to be a typical culinary school
it's meant to be a learning-by-doing
Institute education needs to come with
with care you can educate somebody if
you don't care about them mean hombres
Mario hanya pasa tormentas soy
supervisor edema serous heat ambience
tempo kendama sandal area the so malaria
this day moment oink a saint rocky best
keto OS product of Olivia no que ninguna
otra lado digamos luan Jabbar Larissa
vestroia bare K goes to low edge due to
a cambiado mi vida there's a lot of
potential there's a lot of energy
there's a lot of pride one of the big
things we're doing is empowering people
yes
it's a movement that that touches the
whole society